- [sings in Spanish]
I MADE YOUR FAVORITE:
FRENCH TOAST AND BACON--
- GRACIAS, CONSUELA.
DID YOU CUT THE CRUSTIES OFF?
- SI,MIJO.
- BUT WHAT DID YOU DO?
WE WANTED MONTE CRISTOS.
- DON'T EVEN WORRY "ABART" IT.
WE'RE PRETTY, UH,
OXY-CONTENT, RIGHT NOW.
- YEAH, WE ALREADY ATE A BIG
VICO-DIN-DIN.
[both giggle]
- NO GOOD!
- THAT'S THE LA--
NO!
NO, YOU DON'T D--
- WENDY, WHAT ARE
WE SUPPOSED TO DO?
THAT WAS THE LAST
OF OUR STASH.
- WE JUST HAVE TO
HUNTER S. THOMPSON
DOWN TO TIJUANA RIGHT NOW.
- 'SUELA, WE'RE GOING
DOWN TO MEXICO.
DO YOU WANT US TO SEND ANYTHING
TO YOUR FAMILY?
- [snores]
- ♪ MONEY
♪ BIG MONEY, BIG DOUGH
♪ GET THE PAPER,
GET THE CHEDDAR ♪
♪ GET THE SCRILLA,
MONEY ♪
♪ MAN, I SACK EVERY DAY,
BEND THE BLOCK RIGHT AWAY ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I'M
ALL ABOUT THE-- ♪
[explosion]
- [groans]
QUE PASA, BABIES?
- QUE PASA?
- PERDONAME.
- WE JUST NEED SOME DRUGS.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY GHB OR PURE MDMA?
MAS DINERO.
- HEY, CAN I HELP YOU
WITH SOMETHING?
- OH, YEAH.
- YEAH.
WE'RE JUST LOOKING
FOR SOME SCRIPS, VICS, OXY.
- WELL YOU'VE COME
TO THE RIGHT PLACE, BROTHER.
I'VE GOT THE BEST STUFF
RIGHT HERE.
- LET ME SEE THIS, CHICO.
DUDE, GIVE ME A "BRARK."
THIS IS GRASS CLIPPINGS.
GIVE US THE REAL DEAL,
OR WE'RE OUT OF HERE.
- OH, YOU'RE SMART, HUH?
- I DID HALF A SEMESTER
AT BARD, SO...
- YEAH.
- DON'T [bleep] WITH ME.
- OH, YOU GUYS
ARE REAL GANGSTERS.
- YEAH, MAN, WE LET DMX
PEE ON US ONE TIME.
- SMELLED LIKE VITAMINS.
- HE DRINKS A LOT OF WATER,
THAT'S WHY.
- YEAH, MAN.
- YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA
DO FOR YOU GUYS?
I'M GONNA HOOK YOU UP
TO THE BEST STUFF, OKAY?
BUT YOU GOTTA JUMP
INTO MY VAN.
- DOLPHIN-ITELY.
- FOR SHARKS.
- COME ON.
- COOL, SO IS THIS, LIKE,
A COURTESY SHUTTLE?
- YEAH, CAN WE GET, LIKE,
TINY WATERS OR SOMETHING?
[tires screech]